for you uh what has been kind of like
the last couple of years obviously
you've been just leveling up every every
every year things have been getting
bigger and bigger for you what has been
the negative of that because we always
see the positive we see you got bigger
streams bigger tours bigger money bigger
jewelry but what's the negative of the
success that you have to deal with
it tonight
like like be like a bigger Target it's
just like hmm the bigger you get
more haters yeah it's just a bigger
sight yeah you can make it obviously you
got to move a little differently too
right the bigger you get right yeah
higher profile right what's the dumbest
thing you've bought so far
lean lean yeah
is it still really expensive I mean like
obviously
don't that's just so high it's like hot
because I mean they're like real like
the [__] they're like the activist
shit's like done like I don't even make
it done they don't make that anymore
yeah no if someone has activists they're
lying
or something
it's almost like wine at that point
you're like yo I got this 09 activists
aged fine it'll be brown it's brown it's
not even purple now it's gonna be brown
right now
that's got to be expensive as [__]
like two thousand alone bro my freaking
parents they had uh they had a I think
from like 2004 a prescription bottle
activists in their in their uh oh like
their medicine cabinet I was at my
parents house like maybe like six months
ago and I was trying to find some I had
yes yeah and I pulled this [__] out and
I was like do you guys know what the
[__] y'all got here
like this is probably like I don't know
a thousand dollars at least
see I don't know I never was uh I'm a
big shroom eater I hate shrooms not have
you tried them well how do you hate them
if you haven't tried them I just do what
people say they said to be hallucinating
and [__] listen we can't hate stuff
without trying I ain't trying to loosen
it I do hate crack though I haven't
tried that oh yeah because
I don't know I never thought of it that
way so
shrooms is fire people have told you bad
things about shrimps anything bad
they're just like if you don't like weed
don't transforms so you're not a smoker
I don't like sweet yeah have you never
been a smoker you used to why don't you
like it
paranoia it is or one day I just thought
you're in paranoid how you smoke a lot
though
like like that's like what about eating
weed
Edibles like Edibles would you eat yeah
and I ate one of them for Edibles are
terrible oh I woke up
yeah no you'll wake up the next day
it'll put you down and then you'll wake
up
see you know had a um we infused we
Infuse what like it's like in a solution
but they put in like a wheat slushie
yeah like infused I've had the syrup
that's actually
the homie just gave me this we'll do it
try it it's like a shot
of like I don't know I'm gonna try it
cannabis syrup
this is supposed to be like a Five Hour
Energy Shot but it's
this is sweet yeah yeah but I wouldn't
the thing is you like supposed to pour
this into a Sprite or something oh yeah
yeah now I've never done a weed infused
Slusher you have Yeah by mistake oh
that's [__] up well I gave you that
and laid out on food you shouldn't be
friends with them anymore if they gave
me no I asked for it or come thinking
they come with the food thing to
solution but I'm gonna say Infuse on it
I ain't read it oh hell no then I had to
go report the next week so you had to
did you have to clean up your piss yeah
yeah and then I'm like now I tell my PO
right now I'm trying my mistake he ain't
gonna believe that
so did you tell your PO they ain't piss
me so he was also were you just on
colors which where I'm from they do this
I was on some like a little cool
probation they don't do the color [__]
okay okay because the color is like you
just don't know if you wake up you don't
even know yeah this one like yeah
yo trying to clean up your piss before a
piss test is extremely stressful
activity yeah that is stress you get to
have you drinking some wild shoes on
some [__] yeah and I ain't even had to
pee
and it didn't even make you piss after
no I'm somebody I ain't even text me so
you drank all that for nothing all right
that's what sucks about weed is two
weeks if you if unless you drink all
that [__]
and then you know they say you drink a
lot of water I had my you know how many
times my cousins are all been on
probation my freaking uncles I as a
child have pissed into pill bottles for
them I'm talking at least 50 times
I go in the bathroom I'm pissing in a
pill bottle I'm taking it to my cousin
and then they go and they they'll
microwave it right before they gotta
leave the house so it's like right kind
of like room temperature by the time
they get there and they pour that [__] I
mean unless the PO is watching obviously
but a lot of back then they didn't watch
so like I was pissing for everybody I
was really tripping because I should
have been charging for my fish
did you ever have to use someone else's
pee
like yo let me get some of that yeah the
only thing is is like you get caught
it's like yeah it's a strike for sure
right or is it a violation or how does
that work I don't know I don't think
everybody won't do too much they might
just gonna make you still get pissed you
had to try some true events I'm gonna
hook up with some shrooms try them one
day
I probably try the candy cane no I have
some candy oh yeah yeah listen it's
better than lean
hell no
that [__] stink no no the candy it
doesn't smell it again no you don't have
it ain't that [__]
technically yes yeah do you like
mushrooms on your pizza me either that's
the same as I I mean it's all a fungus
right yeah so technically you're right
mushrooms come from [__] yeah yes but
a lot of [__] I mean look all of our
[__] is uh buried and there's a
fertilizer that's all [__] horseshit
fertilizer I think is put into the into
the ground to make the the ground real
you know the soil and [__] nutrient
and when you bag up if you go to Home
Depot right now you'll buy a bag of
fertilizer that's just [__] bro
so yeah I mean you know mushrooms are
[__] for sure you gotta give it a shot
for you like have you ever tried to get
off a lean
yeah is it tough yeah
it I heard it tastes good I've never
I heard like I had like a homie who was
like he was like real bloated dude right
drink lean every [__] day you finally
got off it took him a long time
within like six months he looked like a
new human being would that be because he
got rid of that lean good see I gotta
lean good without drinking lean that's a
problem this is my beer no I just
[__] I'm just white and old bruh
right it's called Peanut the father at
36. yeah they said when you get that
bill at 30. you can't get that
[__] I've been trying I swear
like I said don't come on
you ain't lying bro I've been trying
bruh I'm 36 and I'm still [__] the
gut is just
I'm not like a fat dude you won't get
the surgery right again I ain't [__]
Batman Kevo bruh I ain't getting no
goddamn BBL I can't do that would you
get a BBL like a a fake six-pack
nah
nah you wouldn't
progress background
I ain't nothing wrong with it huh
whatever makes you happy right right if
you're getting a six-pack makes you
happy if you're getting you know the so
I said whatever you're into whatever
yeah if it helps your self-esteem if it
helps you feel happier when you wake up
all right damn you gotta do it 100